Hi. I'm Abby from Google. Today, I want to show you Google Catalogs.
A fun, new, interactive way to shop all your favorite catalogs on a tablet.
Google Catalogs features the stores and brands you love.
From Williams-Sonoma to Neiman-Marcus, to Sephora and many more.
With Google Catalogs, browsing through a catalog is a rich and engaging experience.
As you browse, you can tap on tags to learn more about products...
...and view inspiring photos and videos.
If you're looking for something specific,...
...Google Catalogs lets you search within or across catalogs.
Google Catalogs also makes it easy to save products that catch your eye...
...by adding them to your favorites.
And when you find an item you like, you can buy it online right away...
...or find it at a nearby store.
If you're feeling creative,...
...you can make a collage from products you saved across different catalogs.
You can choose a background, then arrange and resize pictures and add text.
And when you're done, you can share your collage with a friend...
...or even make it public to other Google Catalogs users.
Bottom line, Google Catalogs makes catalog shopping even more fun and creative.
Visit Google.com/catalogs to learn more and download the app.